[Aplausos]
quando eu penso em localidades a
primeira fase primeira coisa que vem à
minha mente foi a necessidade de romper
com os silêncios e quando eu falo de
silêncio eu não digo necessariamente a
gente responder diretamente a alguém
quando pensa em silêncio eu penso nos
silêncios institucionais
eu penso no silêncio em relação à
naturalização das mortes dos corpos
negros eu penso no silêncio em relação
às desigualdades
eu penso no silêncio quando a gente está
em espaços ou num país como o nosso de
maioria negra ea gente não se enxerga a
gente não se vê nos espaços e aí quando
eu penso em silêncio eu penso o quanto
que esse silêncio é construído por conta
da determinação e da imposição de uma
voz única de uma vez sequer falar sobre
nós de uma voz se quer falar sobre o meu
corpo de uma voz que não e que impede
que uma pluralidade de vozes possa falar
então ter direito a voz é ter direito a
humanidade então eu não tenho direito a
voz a minha humanidade está sendo negado
tem uma frase de uma jovem negra que ela
é brilhante ela já participou do ted que
a monique é ver ele que me marcou muito
que ela disse eu nunca fui tímida eu fui
silenciada
e aí eu comecei a lembrar da minha
infância que eu sempre fui uma criança
extremamente é falante com autoestima
que gostava de mim e com o tempo quanto
eu fui me silenciando o tempo conta que
eu fui me invisibilizado por conta dessa
determinação dessa voz única quando
cheguei na escola e não enxerguei no
material didático quando eu cheguei na
escola o silêncio das professoras em
relação às violências que acontecem
dentro do ambiente escolar
e aí eu fui lembrando que um dia me fez
a pergunta é quantos silêncio será que
me compõem e conta de nós muitas vezes
foi os silêncios foram impostos a nós ea
gente acabou silenciando né só que aí
existe uma outra existem pessoas né que
são corajosas e começam a discutir esses
silêncios nem nesse sentido as
feministas negras foi muito importante
na minha formação
a pessoa sobretudo quando eu leio audrey
lloris e ela disse da importância de se
falar senão o peso do silêncio vai
acabar nos engasgando e aí quando a
alice walker disse que não pode ser seu
amigo quem exige silêncio a gente vai
percebendo o quanto que existem outras
narrativas e que essas narrativas são
potentes e que essas narrativas vem
justamente para transcender essa voz
única porque é necessário falar de mim é
necessário que eu possa falar de mim e
que não têm uma voz determinando qual é
o meu lugar é dentro desta sociedade e
aí essas vozes essas múltiplas
narrativas dessas mulheres corajosas
elas vão encorajando a gente também a
falar ela somos encorajando a perceber o
quanto a nossa voz é necessária é e as
pessoas que foram construídas para falar
essas pessoas que geralmente não é são
os homens brancos que tem o poder da
fala o quanto é importante precisamos
perceber a minha necessidade histórica
por falar então não precisa ser negro
para combater o racismo com certeza não
não precisa ser mulher para combater o
machismo com certeza não mas se mulheres
negras pessoas negras não falam mulheres
não falam que tipo de sociedade que a
gente está constituindo porque serão
sempre os mesmos a falar a gente não
rompe com a norma branca masculina então
é necessário para esse sujeito que
sempre teve nesses lugares e fala
entender que muitas vezes o lugar dele
na contribuição dessa luta é ouvir e
entender a nossa necessidade histórica
por falar porque numa sociedade onde
essas rosas não falam numa sociedade
onde essas vozes ou ou quando falam
hierarquizadas porque existe um discurso
autorizado de quem pode falar
a gente não pode falar em humanidades de
fato então quando eu penso em
pluralidade na necessidade de vozes
eu penso que é necessário um novo pacto
de humanidade né porque numa sociedade
onde as violências são naturalizados
onde os silêncios não são questionadas
onde a gente não pensa muitas vezes que
o silêncio diz muito porque a ausência
também ideologia existe muito muitas
coisas por trás dessas ausências
a gente não pode falar em uma unidade de
fato eu acho que quando a gente
verdadeiramente valoriza essas vozes
quando a gente tem uma pluralidade de
vozes
aí sim a gente pode pensar em humanidade
então eu penso que a necessidade da voz
é a necessidade é humano da gente é
conquistar a nossa humanidade de nós
enquanto mulheres negras a gente poder
ser respeitada pelo ser humano que a
gente é porque essa voz que nos
desumanizam aqui nos coloca em lugares
ou da subalternidade ou da islamização
essa voz ela precisa ser quebrada quando
eu penso na pluralidade das vozes de
mulher estranhos de mulheres negras de
homens negros de homens negros gays e
essa multiplicidade de vozes falando o
quanto a gente se torna verdadeiramente
uma sociedade mais rica enquanto que a
gente verdadeiramente tem uma sociedade
muito mais criativa enquanto
verdadeiramente a gente vai ter uma
sociedade humana de fato é porque
enquanto ser mulher negra não ser
considerado humano nessa sociedade
encontra a gente for vistas como objetos
sexuais ou pessoas prata determinadas
posições
a gente precisa reconfigurar essa
humanidade a gente só reconfigura esse
mundo com dessas vozes passam a falar
com essas vozes começam a ser
respeitadas quando essas vozes começam a
ser estimadas estão rompendo o silêncio
é romper com a violência com o pt com
silêncio é a gente romper com essas
violências naturalizados cotidianas e
que muitas vezes a gente não percebe
como violência então é necessário
questionar sim porque quando você está
num espaço de maioria branca e as
pessoas negras que ali estão estão
servindo é necessário você se questionar
por que aquelas pessoas não estão
usufruindo do mesmo espaço como você por
que essas mulheres negras não estão
sofrendo do espaço como eu é necessário
quando a gente chega na universidade ea
gente só tem professores brancos se
questionar por que eu não tenho
professores negros aqui nessa
universidade porque as mulheres negras
desta universidade
elas só estão limpando o banheiro e elas
não estão sentadas no banco desta
universidade
se a gente não rompe com esses silêncios
a gente está admitindo que esse é o
lugar a gente está compactuando com
esses tipos de violência então é
necessário que a gente se incomode de
verdade esses discursos potentes desses
grupos que historicamente não tiveram
voz eles vão incomodar
eles vão incomodar de fato e é
necessário
esse incômodo seja visto como algo
positivo
néné e as muitas vezes esse sujeito que
se sente incomodado em vez de se
questionar o porquê do incômodo ele
dirige a raiva dele para aquele sujeito
que está incomodando ele e mais uma vez
ele tenta silenciar para ele se a voz
única mas sem o incômodo a gente não
promove mudança então é necessário sim
sujeito privilegiado eles incomode
porque se ele não se incomoda ele vai
achar que as coisas estão boas comissão
ele não vai se perceber como responsável
pela mudança ele não vai perceber o
quanto é importante ele se colocar num
lugar discuta e quando falo de escuta de
escuta verdadeira disputa sincera de
quem ouve está disposto a se
desconstruir de quem ouve percebe que a
necessidade dessas outras vozes falar
porque não pode ser meu amigo já disse
isso aqui quem exigiu silêncio e se ele
não me ouve ele está exigindo o meu
silêncio por mais que ele não liga pra
mim tá na boca ele está exigindo o meu
silêncio ele não me ouve e se ele não
considera a minha narrativa como
importante então é importante a gente
questionar por que a gente não lê
mulheres negras porque a gente não lê
obra de pessoas negras porque muitas
vezes as nossas bibliotecas
essas mulheres não estão lá porque a
gente não lê as narrativas porque a
gente não perder não percebe a potência
desses discursos e o quanto é importante
esses discursos para a reconfiguração do
mundo então todos e todas são
responsáveis por isso e é necessário
sobretudo que a gente tenha essa
consciência é que a gente perceba que o
mundo ele vai ser muito mais rico e
muito melhor pra todos nós quando
verdadeiramente a gente vê uma
pluralidade de vozes porque enquanto não
tiver bom para essas vozes que são
silenciados também vai ser bom pra
ninguém
então pensar com esse mundo que a gente
quer de fato se é um mundo onde só
existe uma voz falando o seu mundo em
que essas outras vozes possam falar e
não sejam vistas como vozes menores como
as vozes marginalizados mas como vozes
necessárias e como vozes potentes e
nesse sentido deixa a pergunta é até que
ponto a gente está permitindo que essas
vozes falem e até que ponto esse sujeito
que foram configurados nessa voz única
estão necessariamente
se colocando a responsabilidade de ouvir
nesse sentido o silêncio ele vai ser
importante no sentido de ouvir aquele
que nunca pode falar no sentido de
reconhecer a necessidade histórica de
fala desses outros sujeitos porque não
dá pra gente falar em direito se a gente
não fala do direito a voz se a gente não
reconhece sobretudo direito a fala então
um pacto de hoje humanidade é possível a
partir do momento que a gente reconhece
esse direito ea gente se coloca essa
responsabilidade de verdadeiramente
mudar né então acho que essas vozes
potentes desses grupos que vêm falando e
estão falando não são contra narrativas
meramente e contras discursos são
discursos potentes são discursos que vem
para transcender é silêncio seculares
porque quer colocar de fato a nossa
humanidade e dizer que nós somos várias
possibilidades de resistência e que a
gente quer existe sim mas sobretudo a
gente quer resistir com dignidade
obrigada
[Aplausos]